mexicans right we don't think of in
hip-hop we think of like at least how i
grew up it was hey man little rod mc
magic uh you know going down the list
right but
i don't think that there's really been
like a mexican artist
that's really dropped music
that i've you know as a rapper
that's like on the level that you're on
that also isn't exclusive to mexican
people if that makes sense because you
know if you're listening to little rob
you either had to be from like a mexican
area like i'm from phoenix i'm like yeah
not [ __ ] summer nights is my [ __ ] but
like some kid from like you know
baton rouge ain't going up yeah you know
what i'm saying but you're making like
you know on on a very big stage and kind
of i feel good i think you feel amazing
like i'm making history and i made a
whole new wave and i see a lot of people
following a suit and a lot of kids they
got so much potential doing what i'm
doing
no the the i think the the shout out to
everyone um
suede swifty blue i mean there's so many
dope mexican rappers that are killing it
right now yeah so i feel like baby young
i'm i'm i'm no boy i'm happy as [ __ ]
that i i'm at the forefront of all this
you feel me like i'm really making
history and then they gonna continue
making history
yeah do you feel like you're kind of
like because you are kind of like
leading the way low-key for a lot of
people because you're on the major label
you got the big features you got the big
records you got the big you got the tour
you got the fans you know what i'm
saying the swag man if anything on the
blueprint y'all got to like really pay
attention to what i do and
just try to do it better
when you yeah because i think with what
you do with your brand with the with the
merch with the wii just with everything
i got to be exclusive that's all i'm
saying just how i was talking about the
features man all that feature [ __ ]
that's out the window like
it you i feel like you know when it's
really a good decision and when it's not
like it needs to be thirsty for features
i'm like nah you got to be exclusive
yeah i think you know what they take
your exclusiveness all the way